see this [ __ ] Monday propaganda this  [ __ ] pisses me off all this is doing is  reinforcing people being okay with  hating their [ __ ] job Dustin  I'm enough of this like [ __ ] you should  not hate Monday because it's the start  of the week you should love it we need  to flip the script on this I know a lot  of people don't love their jobs so  [ __ ] fight for it instead of like  using escapism like [ __ ] on Monday  or playing video games or watching  sports or doing whatever the [ __ ] you do  to cope with hating your job how about  spending those hours after the job that  you hate because you have bills to pay I  get it and responsibilities to figure  out how the [ __ ] to get out of it stop  [ __ ] hating Monday it indicates that  you don't like your life you've got one  [ __ ] life are we really gonna just  sit and [ __ ] laugh when Guinness  [ __ ] world records makes jokes about  a shitty day of the week it's the best  [ __ ] day of the week if you like your  life